c'est la page d'accueil de l'application
ça va être la carte des producteurs dans
la prolongation des circuits courts pour
les cantines le département du loiret
créé une application et un guide qui
référencent 300 producteurs locaux avec
l'ange noir et la vente directe a
désormais son guide ses interfaces entre
entre le grand public à l'usagé et le
producteur en fait on va raccourcir les
circuits courts bas c'est un petit peu
cet objectif là ça permet justement
d'avoir dans sa poche ce savoir qu'ils
qui vend quoi où et où je peux le
trouver citrouilles les viandes légumes
fruits tout ce qui se produit chez les
agriculteurs du loiret est désormais
consignée dans ce guide cette vaste base
de données géographiques et alimentaire
offre une formidable visibilité aux
paysans en s'adressant directement aux
consommateurs la plupart des recruteurs
ils sont bons producteurs aujourd'hui on
nous demande donc en circuit coeur
d'otto si bon communicant et ce à la
plupart des agriculteurs on n'est
peut-être pas très bon là dessus c'est
pas notre métier entre parenthèses et
aujourd'hui il ya des gens c'est leur
métier et ils sont là pour et ça c'est
important parce que voilà ça c'est de la
communication
avec cette application est ce guide tiré
à dix mille exemplaires le département
du loiret dans sa compétence d'une
économie de proximité
l'idée c'est ça c'est de toujours
pouvoir accompagner le consommateur
aussi le loire est un qui en recherche
de produits locaux un travail de
référencement qui met aussi en évidence
la nécessité de développer toutes les
productions nécessaires à une autonomie
alimentaire en circuit court